pandémie pertes d'emplois chantier qui
se multiplient les temps sont difficiles
pour montréal bien des résidents et
commerçants sont en colère contre
l'administration plantes
sandrine balthazar est entrepreneur dans
griffintown
je suis extrêmement déçu et mesures
draconiennes voir radical dans
l'implantation de certaines de leurs
promesse électorale au détriment de
notre économie entre elles avaient voté
pour valérie plantes en 2017 mais ce ne
sera probablement pas le cas l'an
prochain elle n'est pas la seule
selon notre sondage presque un électeur
sur deux qui avaient voté pour projet
montréal songerait à lui tourner le dos
c'est comme si la mairesse avait voulu
trop accéléré son programme la mise en
place de son programme orvin la
prochaine élection et que la pandémie lé
contexte de pandémie
le bouleversement que ça reprenne une
dans la vie de beaucoup de gens
ce n'était pas favorable à recevoir
d'autres charges la vôtre ont-ils pour
valérie plantes en 2021 40,6 % des
montréalais sondés jugent que c'est
assez probable ou très probable alors
que 59,3 % répondent peu ou pas du tout
probable
il faut penser aux premières sans losc
laissé ça c'est je pense qu'elle n'ait
pas trouvé tout à fait de juste milieu
jusqu'à dame
j'aime ce qu'a fait caen l'intervention
open jaws en karting sont alliés depuis
qu' on ne coupe il sa filiation je suis
satisfait romont ça dépendrait des
autres partis des autres candidats ce
qu'ils ont à proposer
là présentement je suis pas d'accord
avec tous ses choix
mais les nouvelles ne sont pas seulement
mauvaise pour l'administration plantes
45 % des montréalais se disent
globalement satisfaits de son travail un
pourcentage qui monte à 59 % chez les
jeunes de 18 à 24 ans les deux pires
notes du bulletin
l'état des routes 13 % seulement des
répondants sont satisfaits et la gestion
des chantiers toute satisfaction 18%
c'est inquiétant mais ce n'est pas la
panique totale
c'est un peu normal qu'il y ait de la
satisfaction en ce moment dans une
période où il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
changements à tous les niveaux crise
sanitaire intervention d'administration
mais on est à un an
les élections on ne sait pas quelle va
être la position est ce qu'elle va être
unis le 5 novembre 2017
valérie plante avait été élu avec 51%
des voix dans la prochaine année je
m'attends à voir un certain leadership
de l'administration pour qu'on se sente
plus consultés et écoutés
sandrine balthazar lui donne encore une
chance un an en politique municipale
c'est une éternité ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio-canada m'ont rien